えっと私はえーと京都大学地球環境学堂というところで研究をしておりますあさりと
申しますよろしくお願いします
と前振りしていただきましたが今日の私のあのパートナーでございます
えっとまぁ皆さんたぶんここにおられる方はもうあの小学校の時とかから環境教
行く受けておられたり後テレビでも地球温暖化とか京都議定書とか
あの普通に聞いておられたのでエコとかエコロジーと言ってもあまり新鮮味を多分感じ
られないんじゃないかなと思います
であの実際に私たち大学で後で紹介しますがいろんな活動しているんですけれども
単に環境とかエコって言っても学生さんまったくあの興味を示してくれません
まあただですね京都には実はいろんな
エコな家へとか
心とか暮らしがまだまだ残っているんですね
そういう視点から今日はぜひ京都 this 彼は
していただきたいなというふうに思っておりますそれにあの先ほどご紹介もありました
けれども私たちの生活自身はゴミだけでなくていろんな側面から見て全く
エコでもなくサステナブルでもありませんそう
いう意味でも今日は皆さん何か気づきをあのしていただけたらなと思います今日はです
ねまず紹介したいのがこちら
抜かず兄でありますご存じですかぬか漬け
食べたことはあるけどやったことはないという人が多いんじゃないかなと思います後で
最後やって見せたいと思いますので楽しみにしていてください
しかもですね
これちょっと上げてみますけれどもたイエス特別な額付でして
a
ここにも書いておりますが実は去年の6月からもう1年以上続けています
しかもですね200人以上に混ぜてもらってきました
デマっ子京都府の知事であったり京都の視聴
それからこの方ご存知かも知れませんアメリカのロックフェラー財団のロックフェラー
夫妻
こんな人にも混ぜてもらいましたのでとっても美味しくなっていますっていうことを
話したいわけではなくてですね
なんでこのやっていけないと思われると思いますけれどもこれあの通常は私の研究室の
部屋の廊下に置いてありまして
毎日ような人にあの混ぜてもらっています
で a
それをですね他にも出てるだけではなくてまぁ facebook で毎日ですねエコ
メッセージとともに発信しています
でそれがあのまあ sns を使って学生さんも含めていろんな人にこういう活動を
知ってもらいたいというあの学生さんとのディスカッションのアイデアから生まれた
ものです
ですのでこのぬ
かず家そのものはそのエコメッセージの抜刀の役割を果たしています
でもただそれだけではなく抜かずケーっていうのはまあお米の外の小殻の部分ですね
で最近でしたら捨てられることもあるんですそれに水としようという非常にシンプルな
ものを混ぜて
ぬか床
というベッドですねお漬物のベッドでそれをつくってそこに野菜を入れて
でこれ下手したらまあ1年でも何年でも持つんですよね
でかつ例えば京都皆さんもご存知とり非常に高温多湿で真夏なんかでしたらちょっと
何かをいとこと腐ってしまうと思うんですけれども
このぬか漬けですとそういう時でもおいしく食べられる
でかつその額のいろんな栄養
お野菜が吸い込むことでまた発行するので発酵食品としても非常に健康にも良い食べ物
になるんですね
そういう意味ではもうスーパー健康食品と言いますか
本当に知恵の塊ではないかなというふうに思います
冷蔵庫がなかった時代でもそういうふうに保存して食べる
すごい知恵が詰まっているのではないか
なと思います
一方でみなさんもちろん冷蔵庫持ってますよね
ただ冷蔵庫の奥で干からびた食品
見つけたことは言いませんか絶対一回はあると思うんですよね
でこれなんでしょうか
これは実は145世帯の3日分の家庭ごみから出てきた
食品なんですでしかも普通の職員ゴミは除いてましてこれが基本的に開封されてい
なかったり全く手をつけていない食品ばっかりを集めたんですね
これ全くと9分
5なことではなくて世界中どこであっても必ず
今時こういうゴミが出てきてしまいます
それから典型的な例を見ましょうこれも同じく
家庭のゴミから出てきたものですこれは50世帯の3日分のゴミから出てきた
手付かずの食品なんですけれども非常に特徴て
技でして
ちょっと商品名でてしまってますけどあの真ん中にインスタントのあの麺がありますよ
ね
多分食べたことある人多いと思いますこれそれぞれ3色4食してられているんです
で絶対にこれ5色セットで買ったと思うんですけれどもそういうのが安かったと思うん
ですけれども
結果的には1色2色しか食べていないの
でたぶんすごい高い買い物をしたのではないかなと思いますし
また非常にもったいないですよねそれから
こっちちょっと暗くて見にくいかもしれませんけれども
この上の方とですねここにあの上はおかしいですチーズケーキでした
それかこっちはあの佃煮みたいなもんですね
でこれ京都の調査だったんですけれどもそれぞれ東京の名物です
多分年末の調査でしたので
貰い物お土産でもらったものではないかなと思います
そういうものでも
まあ食べられていなかったりへ
お裾分けする相手がいなかったりするとこういう形でゴミになって出てしまう
それから最後にもう一つの特徴をみておきたいと思いますけれどもこういうところ
皆さんの家にも必ずあるんじゃないかなと思いますけどインスタントのものとか完走し
たドライフーズですね
これ実際のところまったく開封されていませんで多分
見ることもなくにおいをかぐこともなく舐めて見ることもなく
日付だけを見て切れていたから捨てたんだろうと思います
こういうものがもうわんさか出てくるんですよねまあそういう意味ではこの額付
この知恵は一体どこに行ったんだろうというふうに思わた子たちの生活です
でこの中で行ったことある人たぶんいないとあまり少ないんじゃないかなと思うんです
けれどもこれ学生さんにももちろんやってもらってます
でだいたいまずを開けてですね匂いに衝撃を受けます
それから感触ですね意外と感触って想像できないですねもう何とも言えないんです
あとで興味ある人は是非行ってみてくださいそれから
音ですねなんと言えない子しっとりした音がするんです
そして美味しいそういう意味では私たちが先ほどの職員ゴミのように五感を使ってい
ない
そういうものすべてをフル活用できるぬか漬け
私は勝手になんですけれどもスーパー環境教育教材に認定したいと思っています
ん
ちょっとあの喋りすぎて喉が渇いてきましたので次に移らせてもらいますね皆さんもお
茶を持ちの方ぜひ飲んでください
8ちょっと一服ということでハイあの
まあこれあの岩化してきたんですけれども人肌ぐらいに冷ましております
デフ実はたぶん日本で一番高いあのお茶なんです
京都府産のお茶なんですけどねですのでかなり甘みが多分たっぷりですので旨み
たっぷりお茶はば
人肌ぐらいに冷ましても十分を
美味しく飲めますこれは私は最近ちょっとハマっております
飲みたい人たぶんいますよね
何人かだけ行けるかな
まああの私が一番多分喉渇いてるんで
ヘへ流してもらいますねさっきに
あの上等なお茶は旨みがたっぷりなんですですのでスープみたいな味なんです
失礼します
あーをしねごめんなさいね一人だけちょっと
せっかくなんでこのおいしさを味わっていただきたいなと思います
誰か
どうですか
はいじゃあそのきょろきょろして言うあなたに
あのまえっと本来でしたらねもっとゆっくり味わいたいですし
今ね飲んでもらったカレーとも語らいたいわけです
そういう意味ではこういうお茶の時間たぶん日本だけじゃなくてあのいろんなところに
きっとあったと思うんですよね
ただ残念ながらたぶんほとんどの人が
は皆さんペットボトルを持って歩いてるんじゃないかなと思いますし
思わず喉乾いたらまあ自販機に駆け寄って買ってしまうんじゃないかなと思います
でもほんとはね今日こんな貴重な時間をシェアさせてもらいましたけれども一緒に
楽しむ
こういう時間も大切にしたいなとマイナスをに言ってますけども
あの実は私これ目覚めたの動く最近で今年の6月
先ほどのあの学生さんと一緒に活動しているぬか漬けの第2弾を考えようということで
話している中でお茶
いけるんじゃないかということであのインストラクターの方がおられるんですね
しかも抹茶とかだと難しいんですけれどもこう
いうリーフ茶を美味しく淹れる入れ方を習いました
でやっぱり習うと30分ぐらいじっくり学生さんとも一緒に議論をして楽しむ
そんな時間を持つことができました
そういう意味では先ほどの漫画に戻りますけれども便利になっていきましたよ確かに
なってきましたがそれとともに失った時間とか
まあ心豊かさとかコミュニケーションとかそういうものもあるんじゃないかなと思い
ます
それに後でちょっと話しますけど
誤飲を様子も変わってきているとちょっとこれインプットしてみてください
そういう意味ではまあお茶のそうですけど私はお茶の時間もひっくるめてあの認定し
たいなと思っておりますよろしいでしょうかね
はいうんと言っていただきましたありがとうございますででへ先ほどのお茶の時間の
漫画でちょっとゴミにも注目してくださいというに申し上げましたが
このグラフとても貴重なデータです
越冬明治37年から始まっております真の100年間のグラフになっております
何かといいますとまあ京都市のゴミの量家庭ごみの量を示したグラフになっておりまし
て
なんとなく様子分かって頂けますでしょうかこれゼロっていうところわかりますかね
これ何があったか
これちょうど第二次世界対戦の時ですね真のデータがなかったというのもありますけど
も
まあ極めてゼロに近かったと思いますそしてません50年ぐらいはほぼあの戦前レベル
だ
あったのがここですね昭和30年代後半ぐらい
1960年代ぐらいにこの急カーブを遂げました
これ背景わかりますよねで多分恋日本だけじゃないと思います
であの
バクッと言いますとそのマスプロダクションます今3ぷしょん
そしてまあますディスポーザルて花王エストという
こういうシステムの変化があったんだと思います
で時代としてはとても良かったと思うんですけれども
ただモノを売る買うという立場から実はこういう考えが後ろにあったんですね
これは日本の統治のまあ大手広告代理店が
ものを得るための戦略として出した
10分というもので web なんかにもをしておりますがもっと使わせろ
捨てさせろ無駄使いさせろ季節を忘れさせろ贈り物をさせろ
組み合わせで買わせろ
きっかけを投じろ流行を送りさせる気安く合わせる混乱作らせということで
こう見るとに判定負けているんだろうというふうに思ってしまうんですが
ただ実際私たちの生活はまさにそういう風になっていると思いませんかね
声を変えないといけないというふうに思うんですがなかなか簡単ではありません
こちら私が気に入ってる漫画の一つなんですけれども
ま蛇口がありますそこから資源エネルギーがどんどん社会に流れてきています
大量生産大量消費ですよねでその後先生先生とこう
資源を戻してリサイクルをしているわけです
たぶん皆さんも持ち替えたペットボトルはだ
ってやっぱり最高に出してるんじゃないかなと思いますでもこれでは全く追いつかない
まあそれが今の世の中なんですねここの人が指差しています
元栓を閉めた方が早道せないかもその通りなんですねとってもシンプルなんですけれど
も
でもあれ閉めるとどうなるでしょう
今現在は大量生産大量消費ん
それに伴って経済が成り立ってますので
あの元栓を閉めると経済が止まってしまう
多分それが単純な回答だと思います
ただ
私のまあ思う解決策というのは蛇口を閉めて資源エネルギーを減らしても流れる
お札の量を変えないまあそういうことを意味するかというと
できるだけ少ない資源エネルギーから高い価値の商品とか
サービスを生み出す
そういう転換をしなければいけないと思いますただそのヒントが京都にはたくさんある
とも思いますのでぜひ皆さんと一緒に探していきたいなと思います今日と小さくて高い
ものいっぱいありますよね
例えばあぶらとり紙女性だったら知っていると思いますけれども
あれ多分コピーをしちゃったら何
10枚と帰るぐらいの値段で売られているとても付加価値が高い商品です
そういうものを増やしていく京都の知恵はまだまだ活用できるんじゃないかなと思い
ます
もう一度先の先ほどのグラフに戻ってみたいと思いますが先ほどは9球
像に注目しましたが最後に皆さん希望を持っていただきたいので最後の方もちょっと見
てもらいたいと思います
で京都もま日本もそうなんですけれども
ごみの量は2000年ですねミディアムの年にピークになってますあそこですね
で京都はそこから半分に減らすという目標を立てて頑張っています
ゴミを有料化したり分別を増やしたりそんなこともしてい
ますが中でも極めつけが始末の心条例という条例を制定しました
これは日本にも世界にもかなり先駆けた取り組みだと思います始末の心を聞かれた事
ある方おられた嬉しいんですけれども
始めと終わり始末ですねええ
英語で言うとライフサイクルで考えると言ったらいいかもしれませんけれども
ものの生まれた時からしてる時までを考えて裁量に使おうという考え方です
で英語の今のあの技術的な考え方に置き換えますとそれは
reduce
リユースリサイクルでありませんよそれ以外の2つに着目しようではないかという考え
方ではないかなと思います
つまりゴミになるものをもともと減らそう
それから一度使ったものは繰り返しできるだけ使おう
これ私きてるのも実は母の着物なんですけれども
最近コーナー来ませんので
リメイクしてみましたまあそれもリリースの一つだと思います
そういうことをしてみようというこの始末の心
これ私は本当に重要な
心であり教材ではないかなというふうに思います
こんなのもありますねーもう話しだしたらキリがないんですけれども
とても有名な観光地です足るを知るっていうことが昔からデザインされているんですね
とてもシンプルな考え方なんですけれども本当に実現するのは難しいことですがこう
いうこと
羽毛学びの場があるんではないかなというふうに思っています
ぜひ皆さん発掘していただきたいと思います
そしてちょっと様子が変わりましたがこちら
私が最近ゴミの研究でフィールドにしている国の一つソロモン諸島というところです
太平洋に浮かぶ小さな島国なんですけれども
もうゴミの処理が全く追いつかなくて
で海岸中ゴミで埋め尽くされています
こんな島がたくさんありますてしまうだけでなくて途上国の多くの場所ではこういう
状態になっています
ただこれってそんなに珍しい話ではなくてこちらもご覧いただきたいと思いますが
白黒なんでちょっと歴史を感じるかもしれませんけれども
これ1970年の東京のやつなんですね
東京京都もそうでしたからという彼はゴミで埋め尽くされてたんですねこれ何だと思い
ますかこれも可能
なんですけれども雪の間ボートで
入ってるじゃないんですよこれツリーしている漁師さんなんですけれどもこれは洗濯機
が普及して泡だらけになった彼はなんですね
この間を漁師の人が漁をしていたとこんな時代もあったんです
ただ今私たちはこれを技術で乗り越えて美しい京都
日本をつくっているわけです
そういう意味で多くの人が途上国からも私たちのことをまだ見に来てくれているわけ
ですけれどもこういう技術で開発する
その知恵も私たちがまあ提供すべき重要な知見だと思うんですが
先ほどの京都の地へ心そういうところも合わせて
発信することができるんじゃないかなと思っております
最後になりましたがあの紹介しておかなければいけない私の大切な助っ人ですか私の
恩師でもあるんですけれども
高槻先生という京都大学の名誉教授の方です
ゴミの研究をずっと続けてこられましたが同時に高槻
そのまま英語にしまして漫画も書いているそんな人です
そんな人の漫画をちょっとつ変わった
て頂きましたので興味があればまた見ていただきたいなと思います
こんなところにもあるんですよあのあすいませんハイあの京都のにお住まいの方は京都
市のゴミ袋にこれを可愛いくるし
かわいいかわいくなくしたあのキャラクターが乗ってますけど実はこんなに可愛いので
また見ておいてください
a 忘れてはいけませんあの時間がきましたけれども最後にぬか漬けを混ぜさせて
いただきたいと思いますのでぜひご注目いただきたいと思います
でなのこれ六段は学生さんが一生懸命やってくれておりましてそのときのちょっと引用
も来ないといけないので
でっさせていただきますけれども
へと行ったことある人おられますか
行ったことある人って上げてもらっているかあ
少ないですねちょっとだけられますね
これはあの
技の名前がございまして10違うしと言います
天と地を返すんですね
でこれし結構深いんですで下のほうには空気が行きませんので
嫌気性の菌がいますで上の方は空気に触れてますので
好気性の菌がいてそれがうまく子矯正してまーおいしく発行しおいしいぬか漬けに
なるんですねそういう意味では本当に先人の知恵が詰まっているものだなぁと思います
今日はお茶を飲みましたけど
あとはこれでグイッと一杯ビールを生かしていただいてええ
今日の打ち上げにしたいなーなんて思ったりもしておりますが
あのぜひと小分けもできますのでちょっとやってみようかなという方は来ていただけれ
ば大変うれしいです
それではあの私からのアイディアということで終わらせていただきたいと思います
ありがとうございました
[拍手]